It might be because of the overflow of love.
It might be difficult to appreciate more like genuine little moments of love.
And it's not for me.
No.
Um,
I,
I spent a lot of time thinking about that and I also spent a lot of time
thinking about how titanic bizarre my place in the world is.
I mean I,
I think about it a lot and I spent a lot of time being poor and being a loser.
I mean my,
my childhood was not the best.
I went through a lot of struggle when I was young that I cooling to like a
safety rep raft.
You know,
I,
I don't,
I don't ever think there's something special about me and I tried to let
everybody know that you,
anybody could do what I've done it.
You just have to just keep going though.
The,
it's like 99% of this thing is just showing up and keep going,
keep improving,
keep working at things and keep going.
Put the time in.
But the interesting thing is you haven't actually a couple of days ago,
went back to your first podcast and listen to it.
You haven't really changed much.
So you were,
I mean the audio got a little better and,
but just like the year,
the genuine nature of the way you interact hasn't changed.
And that's fascinating because,
you know,
fame changes.
People
was already famous then.
I just was finding a different way.
Yeah,
I was famous.
I was already famous from fear factor.
I was already already had stand up comedy specials.
I already had.
Um,
I had already been on a sitcom.
it wasn't as famous as I am now,
but I understood what it is.
I'm a big believer in adversity and struggle.
I think they're very important for you.
It's one of the reasons why I appreciate martial arts.
It's one of the reasons why I've been drawn to it as a learning tool,
not just as something where it's a puzzle that I'm fascinated to try to figure
out how to get better at the puzzle.
And martial arts is a really good example because you never really the best,
especially when there's just so many people doing it.
It's like you're always going to get beat by guys.
And then I was never,
I was never putting the kind of time into it as a,
an adult outside of,
uh,
my taekwondo competition.
I was never really putting all day,
every day into it.
Like a lot of people that I would train would,
and so I'd always get dominated by the really best guys.
So this certain amount of humility that comes from that as well.
But there's,
there's a struggle in that you're learning about yourself and your own limits
and the limits of the human mind and endurance and just not understanding all
the various interactions of techniques and that,
you know,
there's some,
there's humility to that in that I've always described martial arts as a vehicle
for developing your own human potential.
But I think marathon running has similar aspects.
I think when you're just,
you figured out a way to keep pushing and push through the control of your mind
and your desire and overcoming adversity,
I think overcoming adversity is critical for the human.
For humans.
We have this,
this,
um,
these,
this set of reward systems that are designed to do,
to reward us for overcoming,
for overcoming obstacles.
For overcoming a relationship,
struggles for overcoming physical limitations,
and those rewards are great and there are some of the most amazing moments in
life when you do overcome,
and I think this is sort of engineered into the system.
So for me,
fame is almost like a cheat code.
It's like you don't really want it.
Don't dwell on that man.
Like that is the,
that's like a free buffet.
Like you don't,
you know,
you want to go hunt your own food,
you want to make your own fire,
you want to cook yourself and feel the satisfaction.
You don't want people feeding you grapes while you lie down.
What is the hardest things?
He talked about a challenge a lot.
What's the hardest thing you've,
when we'll,
have you been really humbled
martial arts for sure.
The Marzano.
Humbling.
Yeah.
From the moment I started,
I mean,
I mean I got really good at taekwondo,
but even then I'd still get the fuck beaten out of me by my friends and got
training part.
Especially when you're tired and you're doing your,
you're rotating partners and guys are bigger than you.
It's just,
it's just humbling,
you know,
martial arts.
Very humbling.
I got to call you out on something.
Um,
so you talk about education system sometimes I've heard you say is a little
broken in high school and so on.
And I'm not really calling out,
I just,
I just want to talk about it cause I think it's important.
Uh,
and as somebody who loves math,
he talks,
but your own journey was school didn't give you
a passion value.
Well you could maybe talk to that,
but I,
for me,
what I always,
maybe I'm sick in the head or something,
but for me math was exciting.
The way martial arts.
What were exciting for you?
Because it was really hard.
I wanted to quit.
And the idea with education I have that,
that that seems to be flawed nowadays a little bit is that we want to make
education easier,
that we want to make more accessible and so on.
Uh,
accessible of course is great,
but you kind of forget in that and that those are all good goals.
You forget in that,
that it's supposed to be also hard and like teachers.
Just the way you're wrestling coach,
if you like quit,
you say,
I can't do anymore.
I have to come up with some kind of excuse.
You're wrestling coach looks at you once to say get your ass back on the mat.
The same way I wish math teachers did that.
When people say it's almost like cool now to say,
ah,
it's not,
math sucks and that's not for me,
or science sucks as buzz teacher's boring.
I think there there's room for some
culture or says,
no,
you're not.
If you just put in the time and you struggle,
then that opens up the universe to you.
Like whether you become an Neil degrasse Tyson or the next fields,
medal winner and mathematics.
I would not argue with you for one second.
I would also say that one of the more beautiful things about human beings is
that we vary so much and that one person who is just obsessed with playing the
trombone and to me,
I don't give a fuck about trombones,
but that's okay.
Like I can't be obsessed about everything.
Some people love golf and they just want to play it all day long.
I've never played golf a day in my life.
Set Miniature Golf and just fucking around,
but that doesn't,
it's not bad or good and I think there's,
there's definitely some skills that you learned from mathematics that are hugely
significant if you want to go into type of fields that you're involved in.
Um,
for me it's never been appealing,
but it's not that it was just difficult.
It's also that it just,
for whatever reason,
who I was at that time in that school with those teachers having the life
experience that I had,
that was not what I was drawn to,
but what I was drawn to his literature,
I was drawn to reading,
I was drawn to stories.
I was drawn to possibilities and creativity.
I was drawn to all those things.
You are an artist of it too.
Yeah.
I used to be,
I used to want to be a comic book illustrator.
That was,
that was a big thing when I was young,
I was really into comic books.
I was really into,
um,
uh,
it was traditional comic books and also a lot of the horror comics from the
1970s a black and white,
like creepy and eerie.
Did you ever see those things?
Creepy and Eerie?
Like black and white?
Yeah,
they were,
they were a comic book series that,
um,
existed like way back in the day was all there.
We're all horror and they were like really cool illustrations and these wild
stories,
but it was comic books,
but they were all black and white.
That's creepy and eerie.
Oh,
that's the actual name.
Yeah,
Erie and creepy.
Where the nae see like that was from,
what year was that?
It says September,
but it doesn't say what year,
but I used to get these when I was a little kid.
Man,
I was like eight,
nine years old in the 70s.
Good and evil.
Yeah,
it was,
uh,
there were,
there were my favorite,
like that's a cover of them and like they would have like covers that were done
by like Frank Frazetta,
Boris Valais Ho and just really cool shit.
And I was fat.
Those.
I love those.
When I was little,
I was always really into horror movies and really into like Bram,
like look at this werewolf one that was one of my favorite ones.
That was like crazy werewolf that was like on all fours.
Who is the hero?
Usually Superhero heroes.
Everybody dies.
And those,
that's the beautiful thing about it.
Everybody gets fucked over.
There was nobody.
That was the thing that I really liked about them was that like nobody made it
out alive.
There was no one guy who figured it out and rescued the woman and they wrote off
in the sunset,
you turn the corner and they'd be a fucking pack of wolves with glowing eyes
waiting to tear everybody apart.
And that'd be the end of the book that I just,
um,
I was just really into the illustrations.
I found them fascinating.
I just,
I love those kind of horror movies and I love those kinds of illicit,
so that's what I wanted to do when I was young.
Yeah.
I think the education system is probably,
we talked about creativity is probably not as good at,
uh,
inspiring and feeding that creativity because I think math and wrestling can be
taught systematically.
I think creativity is something,
well actually I had known nothing about it,
so I think it's harder to take somebody like you when you're young and say and
inspire you to pursue that fire,
whatever's inside.
But one of the best ways to inspire people is by giving them,
uh,
giving them these alternatives that are so uninteresting.
Like saying,
you're going to get a job selling washing machines and you're like,
fuck that.
I'm going to figure out a way to not get a job selling washing machines.
Like what some of the best motivations that I've ever had been terrible jobs
because you have these terrible jobs and go,
okay,
fuck that.
I'm going to figure out a way to not do this.
You know,
and whether you want to call it add or Adhd or whatever it is,
it makes kids squirm in class.
I didn't score them in every class.
I didn't squirm and science class,
I didn't squirm in,
in,
you know,
an interesting subjects.
There's things that were interesting to me that I would be locked in and
completely fascinated by.
And there was things where I just couldn't wait to run out of that room.
And I don't know what the reason is,
but I do know that a lot of what we call our education system is engineered for
a very specific result.
And that result is you want to get a kid who can sit in class and learn so that
they could sit in a job and perform and that for whatever reason,
that was just,
I mean,
I didn't have the ideal childhood.
Maybe,
maybe if I did I would be more inclined to lean that way.
But I didn't want to do anything like that.
Like I couldn't wait to get the fuck out of school,
so I didn't ever have to listen to anybody like that again.
And then just a few years later,
I mean,
uh,
you graduated from high school and you're 18.
When I was 21,
I was a standup comic,
and I was like,
I found it.
This is it.
I'm like,
good.
I found there's an actual job that nobody told me about where you could just
make fun of Shit and people go out and they pay money to hear you.
Uh,
create jokes and routines and bits really.